[Musique]
bonsoir mes chers petits amis vous savez
que p'tit louis et mirabel sont ma foi
de plus en plus sage
j'espère que vous aussi des petits
enfants qui m'écoutait vous faites
plaisir à vos parents d'accord gros
source
mais je t'en prie ne me fais pas trop
attendre ce produit sans crainte patron
au record pour propos
[Musique]
ce soir les enfants
tu voi annonce j'ai pu tout mon
médicament tout seul oh c'est très bien
petit louis tu es vraiment un homme tu
fais bien de raconter mais bien sûr les
enfants
une très jolie histoire que m'a raconté
mon papa
c'est l'histoire de la petite améthyste
et de la balançoire vous la connaissez
[Musique]
voilà y avait une fois il ya bien
longtemps
une petite fille qui s'appelait amétis
pourquoi me disent tu parce qu'elle
avait de grands yeux tout bleu couleur
d'une jolie pierre précieuse qu'on
appelle améthyste
elles vivent à ganges et de grandes
forêts avec ses parents et avec les amis
de ses parents
les animaux ils habitaient dans des
maisons de paille
le papa de la petite améthyste partait
tôt le matin travaillé dans la forêt sa
maman allait faire les commissions et
améthyste jouait tout seul dans la
grande forêt elle n'avait pas peur vous
voulez si vous avait toujours peur bien
sûr que non
tous ses amis jouaient avec elle devaux
lisoie zoo de toutes les couleurs et
elle jouait aussi à cache cache avec les
biches et les chevreuils mise en ligne
ils sont jeunes ils étaient tous très
gentils avec elle sauf un fim un serpent
un gros tigre et cet énorme crocodile
qui aurait bien voulu la manger c'est
pas gentil ça on en sait peu gentil du
taudis dans les parents d'améthyste lui
avait bien recommandé de faire attention
mais un jour qu'elle était parti trop
loin dans la forêt elle rencontra le
gros crocodile la bouche ouverte tout
près à la manger quand tout à coup
800 l'enleva dans l'ère larrat chante
ainsi autant du vilain crocodiles
c'était un gros singe qu'il avait ainsi
sauvé elle avait posé dans un arbre sur
une branche qui bougeait se balançaient
améthyste trouvais cela très amusant
c'était la première fois qu'elle se
balance et elle rien à leur hygiène
cet habitant de ce talent c'est vrai
mais ses parents étaient rentrés à la
maison et l'a cherché partout
il était très élevé où ils en trouvent
un bronze ou le vidame on l'entend dire
qu'ils riaient et relevant la tête il
l'avenir dans l'arbre en train de se
balancer avec le gros singe et ils
furent très heureux de voir qu'elle
avait inventé un jeu nouveau très drôle
qu'on appelle maintenant la balançoire
c'est peut-être un bon tu sais
[Musique]
m
ans
bonnet petit louis bony mirabel
bonne nuit tous mes chers petits amis
embrassez vos parents allaient vite au
dodo et en dormez vous bien sagement
nous reviendrons vous voir sans faute de
main
bonne nuit à demain à te voilà nounours
allons en route
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]